you want to know one announcement I saw
like earlier today just made me sigh
Rick and Morty is getting an anime
wait what Rick and Morty wait who is
getting an anime oh don't tell me how
does that make sense
you're already animation how do they
well like season seven is obviously
still getting made but there is another
separate I guess non-canon like season
that is getting animated by a Japanese
Studio that is Rick and Morty the anime
[Music]
Rick and Morty fans are asking for no
they're not no there's no no they're not
guarantee bro Rick and Morty fans fell
off because of the [__] Justin
roiling [__] yeah yeah how the [__] did
they get green lit I don't know oh what
I am excited about though is the Scott
Pilgrim anime
holy [__] the entire cast as well
I don't know how they're gonna I don't
know how Michael Sarah is gonna be voice
acting but I'm genuinely curious yeah
actually
I mean they got like the entire cast
back and uh They masakiwasa isn't
directing it from what I understand but
they got his Studio to make oh really
yeah yeah and if there's one Studio I
trust to be able to translate yeah the
weirdness uh and the uniqueness of
Scott Pilgrim from live action to anime
it's uh it's science sorry yeah because
I that's that's another thing that's I
do think Scott Pilgrim is like a
one-of-a-kind kind of movie as well
there is no other film that I think
has done what Scott Pilgrim has tried to
do as well as Scott Pilgrim has done
well that's a Edgar Wright film I mean
he's just a brilliant [__] director
well he's a brilliant director that you
know respectfully tries to do something
new yeah every time kind of like
noodling in that sense but and you know
there has been other like kind of like
hey he is like a nerd movie to appeal to
the Nerds you know kind of thing
like well yo he made a video game he
made it hold on let me turn off Mortal
Kombat my favorite movie is Gamers yeah
what Gamers oh the one with Adam Sandler
and Peter Dinklage that's a movie that
was called it's called pixels a game
it's what's it called I think it's
called pixels pixels yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I love that one I love that film
what's uh was it free guy or good guy
free guy free guy yeah that was another
film that was just I didn't know that
was it good okay this guy hey Gamers uh
I don't know Jack uh yeah Sean was in it
I'm always a bit wary when my cousin
like really likes a nerd film because
he's I don't trust this taste
okay dude 's like a [__] brother to
me right but he's he's on the cusp of
just like yes I'm a nerd I like Marvel
movies you know I play video games now
it's now it's into hate on Marvel though
now it's kind of hard is it it's in yeah
it's into hit on Marvel and I don't
think it's into hate on Marvel yeah
that's mainstream now what do you mean
it's amazing I'm a pioneering hating
Marvel movies I've been doing it for
years
Joe he's like my time is like you were
you were kind of a
no one says nice things about Marvel
movies anymore but is it just because
the quality is going down yeah because
it's terrible yeah I bet yeah I mean I'm
I'm still waiting I'm so [__] happy
we finally get different movies yeah
like the next coming years yeah thank
God
if only they did that with there's a guy
anime yeah well all right
the population of Japan has to get bored
with isakai at some point it's Gotta
happen I said that five years ago it's
gonna happen I don't I don't know I
don't know I mean as long as they keep
making interesting isakai Concepts I'm
gonna keep watching I'm I'm Define
interesting
because you know you could say the
vending machine in Sakai is interesting
that's that's not interesting that's
just that's just the dog meme this dog
one that's that's not an easy guy what
do you mean yeah
is actually very similar to like the
whole comic book phase that you know
Hollywood is going through where it's
it's less about okay it's okay isakai
sells people clearly what's the
familiarity it's the familiarity with it
and 99 of isekai [__] sucks ass right
but then you get that that one percent
which is just is genuinely just isekai
Sai just a good [__] story and a good
[__] show same with [__] comic
book movies right you have you know
other comic book movies and then you are
on the off chance you get something like
Joker yeah no I'm not denying that like
you know I might seem like the [__] I
just hate all this a guy like guy but Ah
that's me yeah
there's some good ese guy out there like
of course but yeah you know I feel like
the 99 of the [__] ones could have been
replaced with actually some more unique
interesting Concepts that they're a
[__] plethora of those in the manga
and even the light novel world that just
don't get any attention because the guy
is remained in the same [__] world
I'm calling it now yeah we're trying to
get to the point where we just straight
up remake other animes and just like but
the the premise is that you you isakai
into that anime
they're not going to say it right so
like a picture this someone dies yeah
they appear in another world what's this
they've got a book where you write
someone's name and they die in it like
and they just start repeating aspects of
Death Note so at the end of one piece
Luffy actually dies and then he becomes
a Shinigami with Ichigo and uh I'm
telling you in the next three to five
years we'll get an anime that is just
somebody who he's the guy's another
world and becomes a pirate and there's
like a ton of One Piece references and
it's just [__] dog [__] that just
sounds like a guinea chapter I mean
that's just it they're just gonna start
remaking anime yeah and just slapping on
an Easter guy on it I mean a lot of
times I feel like when I watch an isaka
I kind of just ignore the Easter guys
yeah you have to do that just because it
it kind of feels like I in like 80 80 of
that I watched the Easter guy is
irrelevant to the [__] story of
course but I feel like the old
put that in because he's just like I
need to put Esau in my story somehow
yeah or no one's actually gonna watch or
read my work yeah like yeah I feel like
it's kind of almost kind of like
diminishes the value of the other world
inherently because it's like oh well you
know it's that it's not it's not his
world it's we are the main world yeah
it's like whereas Maiden the best is
like hey this is this is the world yeah
yeah characters their world and that's
the unfortunate thing is that like there
are so many like modern isakai that have
interesting like little bits of Concepts
that would easily stand up on its own
yes but the problem is it [__] you
know it it knee jokes Itself by adding
isekai into it because it's a necessity
nowadays yeah like this is how to get
the kids attentions put it in an
Instagram it's like well you know if you
have an interesting concept you can keep
it in the same world you could you know
I think people have forgotten that the
fantasy genre exists you can just start
in that world you know you don't it
doesn't have to come from a different
world you can just start there no I mean
uh even above that people like I I would
like people to remember that the fantasy
genre uh is more than just the same
starting Final Fantasy Town yeah which
uh is every fancy Andy Sky anime it's
all the same [__] world and it's just
like fantasy it's like dog can I copy
your homework it's like it's like
copying the homework from the guy that
has given his homos to like the 20 other
people in the class and everyone is copy
from the same [__] yeah you know because
like it's interesting you mentioned
about like the World building as well
because like you've seen a rising with
the shield hero yeah yeah like one of
the biggest thing that pissed me off
about writing of The Shield hero is that
it just felt like the whole world was
made around the main character yeah
right like the main character was
obviously like the most competent and
the smartest person in the world but it
wasn't because he seemed like he was
competent or smart it was because
everyone in uh everyone around him was
just [__] stupid yeah it was like if
he said like two plus two is five
everyone would be like [__] you're right
yeah yeah all right
it's the most useless class but actually
it's impressive for how he's managed to
make everything work yeah yeah I feel
and again I feel it's like a big problem
is that like they don't it doesn't feel
like the world exists independent to the
main character yeah it feels like the
world is built around the main character
to make the main character look as cool
and as badass as possible it's like it
felt like it was just like No Game No
Life world but yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly how [__] stupid this world is
yeah exactly and like now around you and
like now that's the peak of that kind of
like stupid power fantasy has come out
which is called Eminence and Shadow
that's like that's as good as it can get
that's that's that's what happens when
you take like you this this is like a
nice guy where it takes all like the
stupid and overpowered tropes bangs
everything up to a hundred makes the
main character as cringy and as Edge
Lord as possible and it just like it's
so stupid and overpowered that it just
becomes fun again right that's like the
peak of the genre that's been done now
isakai so now we can do other avenues
now we can explore other avenues like
taking every immovable object possible
and putting their [__] protagonist
into it yeah yeah that's what I want to
see but
is that what you want to see though I'm
done with it bro I don't know I don't
know I just want to see good shows I've
watched some of your anime back in the
phase of when I would watch anything it
was an anime and there was like
monoliths and that like the main
character had like a cute little girl
that was a [__] cat or some [__] and
they just stayed near the monoliths and
there was a guy in like a top hat and
one of those like uh [__] masks like
the anonymous Oh Black Bullet like
that's it oh yeah how the [__] did I
remember that get that from my dog I'm
the anime man damn it he is the anime
man if you like Black Bullet no it was
[__] it was [__] it had it like the
first half of the first episode I was
like okay this could be interesting this
is how I like and then it just went to
[__] this is how I know unless you've
been watching anime for five plus years
at your opinion on anime is not relevant
yeah it's because I used to think that
[__] was fire and I was like I was like
one year because I was worn you into
watching anime and I thought damn this
[__] isn't yeah yeah yeah the best yeah
but that's you you could replace Black
Bullet with uh akame got killed
you have that phase where
like it's a different length for
everyone but I think everyone has a time
period where you you will not you will
no longer tolerate every anime yeah like
yeah it's the end of the honeymoon
period yeah I think for some people I I
speak to them I'm like holy [__] you've
been in this and you're still going like
eight years strong like how do you how
do you just watch these these guys I
think it's good that's me yeah right
you know you talk about anime and you're
like no it's bad yeah you'll still watch
it which is this insane part yeah you're
out of the question because it's your
job yeah yeah
you're getting paid
okay here's the thing though here's the
thing okay I no way would you watch half
of these used car if you weren't getting
paid most of the time I just read the
Manga actually okay because last time
um but some some music I think genuinely
do have interesting like the the reason
I like isakai isn't the iskai aspect a
lot of the times they a lot of them have
like one really cool interesting idea
that they explore for about a few
volumes and then it stops and then
you're like okay I can move on to the
next one now it's not it's not like the
whole the isekai part it's that one
interesting idea that they explore and
then because it's Easter guys so
disposable then it's just really easy to
like move on from one series to another
because every series explores every uh I
think explores a different thing and
then it's never interesting enough to
hold up for like 10 volumes or something
yeah it's just like yeah I've read it
for like four volumes and I'm done and
then I I can move on to the next
interesting idea
um but like I don't actually I don't
know I do watch a lot of anime but I
feel like I watched less anime than
people think I watch because it's
possible okay so I watch everything when
the season comes out right a lot of that
time I watch that in times two speed
because I [__] have to now because
there's like 50 shows every season uh
but I genuinely only go off and finish
the shows that I find interesting I
think are gonna be good and most of the
shows end up on my end of year list uh
so I end up watching like 20 plus shows
every year which if you if if if you
think about how much people think I
watch I'm sure people think I watch way
more yeah but there's a difference
between the shows I watch and the shows
I finish and I only finish a show if I
really [__] like it oh yeah no yeah
and I feel like that's that's a that's a
big thing because I feel like there's a
reason right there's a reason why the
average score on Mao is like seven out
of ten right because like a lot of
people are like oh people don't know how
to review correctly and I'm like no
you're not gonna go you're not gonna
finish a five out of 10 show I normally
only finish shows if they're 7 out of 10
minimum right see that was the problem I
had yeah even if it was dog [__] yeah I
stuck through all of those until the end
and that's why I'm burnt out see it's it
was only when I could let go of that
feeling of I the completionist side of
you yeah as soon as I let that part go
and I'm just like I'm just gonna finish
what I feel like I tried to do all the
side quests and I found out there was no
end game yeah so like this last season
didn't actually watch anything aside
from villain Saga right that was it that
was all I watched that was one anime
yeah because I've been a song was
[__] incredible but the season itself
pretty [__] actually no actually I did I
did finish one try on [__] oh yes
Trigon was great uh I didn't finish does
it have a good ending what'd you mean
Dragon well it goes in a completely
different direction okay yeah yeah yeah
so have you watched the original watch
the original I thought the ending was
weird Okay throw everything through
everything you know about the original
out the window uh because this one goes
a completely different direction it's
less medic and I would say less
like Western in terms of like it's it's
it leans more into the Sci-Fi it leans
way more into the Sci-Fi aspect which
even just saying sci-fi aspect is kind
of like a soft spoiler if you only are
judging by the original because that
doesn't really come to play until like
halfway through the series but it's less
of uh spaghetti western which is very
reminiscent of the original and it's
more of like here is a weird sci-fi
story in a Sci-Fi world it's more akin
to something like Dune and I I really
like that and holy [__] Studio orange
knocked out the park they don't miss
they don't miss there's a little
spaghetti western huh we don't call
others oh it's because uh the term
originally came from the fact that a lot
of western films were directed by
Italians
oh I literally found this out like two
days ago from a YouTube short so thank
you well you learned something new every
day and I was like that's a [__]
weird way of saying it we don't go like
you know like a Japanese tuna we're like
oh yeah yeah a tuna horror a sushi
Marvel